it appears sort of like we've quietly
gone to war or are about to go to war
there's two different stories that are
really one story that I want to tell you
about today the first is that Donald
Trump has signed an executive order
executive order one three two two three
he signed this late last week and what
this order does is it allows retired
military pilots to be called back into
active duty okay well what's the big
deal right well the legal justification
for that executive order and the
allowing of pilots to be called a by
mandate right forcing them back into
active duty is the emergency status that
was used to defend this quote the
continuing and immediate threat of
further attacks on the United States
that's from title 10 section 688 of the
u.s. code which allows this type of
executive order to be passed in quote
periods of war or active emergency right
now the Trump administration says we are
in a period of war or active emergency
this is effectively pragmatically a
micro draft right it allows the military
to mandate retired officers to enter
active duty this has not been done since
just after 9/11 I believe was the last
time this was done not a lot of coverage
of this but what does it mean does it
mean we're heading towards war in North
Korea is that something related to Isis
where the Air Force has played a major
role but this isn't all the u.s. is also
preparing to put nuclear bombers
nuclear-armed aircraft back on 24-hour
alert does that sound
cold war like to you if it does well we
haven't had that in place since 1991
after the end of the Cold War
there are no winners when it comes to
nuclear weapons and the Trump
administration is facilitating the use
readying the use potentially of those
weapons now from a fiscal conservatism
point of view we already have
submarine-launched able ballistic
missiles and what we're doing by putting
these aircraft nuclear-armed aircraft
24-hour alert is not only dangerous in
terms of the possibility of accident
risk but it's also potentially redundant
because again we have submarine-launched
a bowl ballistic missiles from a morale
standpoint how motivated are people
going to be who get dragged back into
the military after getting out by
executive order and by the way why ban
transgender people from the military if
you're experiencing a shortage and I get
it only a small percentage of
transgender military servicemembers are
pilots but why and there's a possible
side effect here which is the increase
in airline prices because of the
difficulty of hiring pilots the entire
sort of framework of the Trump
administration and the Trump campaign
more more accurately has been it's gonna
be good for the little guy it's gonna be
good for the middle class everything I
do is gonna be good for the middle class
the tax plan will be good for the middle
class
except it's mostly going to be good for
the very rich we are going to be helping
the middle class in every way possible
except doing this and recalling pilots
might make it so that airlines need to
pay pilots more in order to increase
recruiting and of course the airlines
always pass their costs along to the end
user meaning you might pay more for
airline tickets but remember it's
Hillary who's going to start a war and
the lower Trump's approval rating goes
the more desperate that trump is going
to be a going to be in order to seem
presidential in whatever sort of
harebrained way he dreams up and by the
way what happened to this remember when
President Obama was President of the
United States and Donald Trump tweeted
when there was the possibility of
military action against Syria the
President must get congressional
approval before attacking Syria big
mistake if he does not will that be
happening for whatever it is that Donald
Trump has planned even though we don't
actually know what it is that he has
planned or does it not matter anymore
and how worried about this or you
because I
get a lot of emails from our viewers
concerned about economic issues and this
relates to economics concerned about
social issues concerned generally about
Trump's and competence I'm not hearing
from that many people in our audience
with concern about Trump's belligerents
when it comes to use of the military
military has sort of come up recently
because of trumps again total disrespect
of military families gold star families
time and again we've talked about the
Myesha Johnson situation etc but I'm not
hearing that much concern lately about
Trump's sort of desperation and possibly
use of the military out of desperation
to try to take attention away from his
totally abortive presidency if you're
concerned about that let me know the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership